welcome to cloud events with google
cloud
my name is grant merman i'm an engineer
on google cloud
where i primarily work on serverless and
open source
in the next 25 minutes we'll be talking
about the rise of microservices
in serverless computing the cloud event
specification
the industry standard for communicating
events between services
vents for cloud run how you can deliver
events directly to your applications
and finally we'll be showing the
developer experience
along with the demo first
let's give a background to event driven
architectures by talking about the rise
microservices
why microservices well it's easy to
describe with an example
here we have bob's big bad monolith
with these effects your application has
global state
increasing complexity there is often a
complicated orchestration
with non-uniform communication between
services
is group scaling with services scaling
up based off of demand of one powerful
service
a couple dependencies with library
dependencies applying to all services
and it's often difficult to test heavily
requiring box
slow often closed source so in effect
your application does not follow the
single responsibility principle
and can they can sort be described like
a swiss army knife
that's compared to mary's orchestrated
microservice where
you have the following upsides you have
local state
with reduced complexity a request and
response model
where you have clear boundaries of
ownership
only pay when receiving an event
individual scaling and lose spiking
dynamic demand can increase the service
capacity
independently of each other local demand
development and testing is quick and
easy
and you can easily configure access
management with granular
security prayer service
we're in a world where applications are
moving towards
real-time communication well what does
this mean
it means rapid delivery and consumption
of services
so event driven often require immediate
responses
you have many too many messages where
modern applications expect to produce
and consume many events from a variety
of sources
as well as a desire for unmanned
scalability
and costs where modern applications see
dynamic traffic
but really expect to see decreased costs
so once you have decoupled microservices
how do these microservices communicate
with each other well through events
what is an event in programming an event
is an
action or occurrence recognized by
software it
often uh originates asynchronously from
the external environment
the publisher of the event has no
expectation
about how the event is handled the
consumer of the event decides what to do
with the
and notification are discrete units
they're isolated and independent
from each other what is an event-driven
architecture
well it's based off of uh indirect
notifications with an intermediary
or broker you can deliver the full event
data
or just a reference to the external
location that the event can be
found uh this is compared to
a direct pulley between different
services and service oriented
architectures
providing direct access to aps well you
can't really
create a real-time system this way at
least it's
very hard so events make applications
complicated
but in practice developers simply want
to make
applications work and not really think
about uh conceptual eventing systems
managing events is important but
cumbersome
as a developer you have questions like
what happened
what type of event did i get who sent
the event
where's the event from uh when was the
event sent is it a duplicate
is it created recently and
moreover every event has its own
different format
what if there is a common machine
readable standard for events
well introducing the cloud event
specification a common way
for describing events but here's the
premise
events are everywhere yet event
publishers tend to describe
events differently especially with
respect to burgeoning
payload formats and subtle payload
differences that may
break your application the cloud events
is the specification for describing
events event data in a common way
it's brought to you by the cloud native
computing foundation serverless working
group
a group of developers across the
computing industry creating standards
for more compatible services
at the core cloud events is an envelope
for information
about the occurrence of change in the
system
i like to think of it like a one-way
letter with a from address
and no to address
the cloud event format has the following
properties
the cloud events carry facts and
metadata with standard attributes
they do not prescribe what you do with
these facts they're self-contained
meaning you don't need to attach any
information to the event
is the whole picture the event format
itself is lightweight
or unique within a source you can encode
them in different formats without losing
or modifying information
such as jsonbison avro etc
and doesn't talk about any http methods
api services just talks about the hp
mapping
i think it's really uh easiest to
understand cloud events by seeing some
examples
so let's say we're a web application on
top of gcp
um here we have some example events that
you might see in your application
a new photo is uploaded a new generic
message is published to a topic
maybe a new user or a new audit log is
recorded
whenever maybe a new vm is spun up in a
project
these are different events you might see
so as a developer i have some questions
about
well the event being delivered to my
system
well what kind of event did i get uh
when was it sent
who sent it to my service what's the
event's unique identifier
what's the shape of the event data and
what is the event data
well this corresponds to the following
quadrant fields of
type time source
id data schema and the data field
now if we fade out the questions
and left align the properties these
functory are new
and specify the version of the payload
the spec version property
add some data you get a cloud event
this is an example of cloud that you
might see from pubs up
so more about the spec can be seen on
github
let's dive deeper into that
specification
every cloud event has a set of required
and optional attributes
there are four required ones with some
examples
you have the id which is a string
identifies the event the source plus id
must be
unique the source is a uri identifies
the context
the spec version the string the cloud
event uh spec version
to be used with that event like 1.0 or
0.3 then you have uh
the time the type attribute which is a
string
uh value identifying the type of that
and the cloud events may have some
optional
attributes in this format or you can
have data
well it can be anything on its domain
specific information about the currents
a data content type the string the mime
media type
rc 2046 such as application json
uh you have your data schema which is a
uri
that identifies the schema the data
attribute
in google's case we use pros
subject is uh strength this is the
subject of the event
it's really useful for filtering and
time is the timestamp the time of when
the currents happen
other attributes are allowed but just
not standardized
there are two primary modes for encoding
cloud events
send via the http protocol use binary
encoding
or structured encoding these are called
content modes in the cloud event
specification
let's go over that here on the right
hand side you have an hp request with
the cloud map
using binary encoding at the top you see
an http post to slash
with some standard hp attributes uh
there's some context attributes with the
hp header
header prefix of ce dash you're free to
add other headers to
and then you have the cloud event body
which is the full hdb body
this encoding is used by events for
cloud brand
that's compared to structural encoding
where we have
the context attributes under the first
level properties of the json object
and the data attribute under the data
property this encoding is
used by cloud functions for example so
what does this look like in practice
well your service
will receive an http request within that
http request it's a cloud event
then within that cloud event you have
some metadata data these cloud event
uh standard attributes and your event uh
payload
so that's the cloud event it should be
very clear what a cloud event
is so let's go and move on
now let's talk about events for cloud
run cloud run
is a fully managed computing platform
for deploying
scaling to analyze applications quickly
and securely
use any language abstract infrastructure
management the sample developer
experience
it's built on the open k native standard
events for cloud run makes it easy to
connect your applications
from a variety of sources
and takes care of front integration
delivery
security and authorization with error
handling for you
which all in all improves developer
agility and your application's
resilience the long-term vision is to be
able to deliver events
from a variety of sources to cloud run
and custom syncs
currently you can deliver events
from google cloud sources via cloud
other blogs that pops up
to cloud run so going back to the event
examples we
had described before whenever a new file
is uploaded to google cloud storage
a new message is being published to pubs
up
or a new audit log is created you can
now trigger cloud run services
directly from events via events for
cloud run
the way events for cloud run works is
like this you can trigger your service
from a variety of sources cloud storage
pub sub cal
and your events will go through um
events for cloud run and this will uh
send an hp request
to your cloud run sync with a cloudant
payload
let's break that apart on the left you
have some
event producers our sources with sources
you can um
describe the event sources and describe
the event types
just just describe all event types in
the center
you have a clever one service where you
can go and manage your triggers
you can create new triggers specifying
the vent source for example
uh cloud sources via cloud audit logs
or custom applications via pops up and
you have your
credit operations for triggers like
listing triggers deleting triggers and
describing triggers
these triggers specify your sync which
is your cloud running service
specified by name the three modes
of interaction for configuring events
for cloud brand
use the console ui vcloud cli
or rest api let's go over them
but the cloud event cloud run ui allows
you to easily create triggers
uh just on cloud.hustle.com
simply uh specify your event source
create and done
currently you'll be using the cloud cli
after installing the alpha components in
g cloud
just type g cloud alpha events to get
started
zooming into the alpha events command we
specify the trigger name
the target service
and the event type and we have some
optional uh
parameters used for filtering like the
service name
method name and resource name in this
case uh this is a command
used for google cloud storage lastly
you can use the cloud run api if you
really want
you might be asking what's the
difference between cloud run for
anthony's
employee manage what's the difference
the differences are here in summary
fully managed
has a simpler trigger setup is google
managed but has
fewer event sources currently and it can
only trigger cloud run services
not any kubernetes service or arbitrary
urls
tldr use events for gke and using
gpe next we'll be running through the
developer experience and some useful
tools when using event cloud
first up is the cloud advanced sdk
the cloud event sdks are a lightweight
set of libraries
designed to speed up your integration
with cloud events
uh within your application they can do
three things
you can create cloud events center cloud
events and receive cloud event
a language dramatic way there's a spec
on github
practically speaking um this means that
you can transform
your hp request from this
to this extracting the cloud event
object these sdks are available in the
following languages
in node go python java ruby hp
and.net the code is open source on
github
and here's a little dystonia where
you'll i can use these
images trust me so within a cloud event
each event type has its own data format
so what's the structure of that data
well we've described the source of truth
for the structure of the data in
protobox
these protobufs contain the cloud event
type which is a string
and the cloud event data which is the
full message description
on the right hand side you can see an
example of what protobuf
used for cloud pub sub these
have been published in github and we'll
be adding more event types
as the events are supported based off
the source
of truth as mentioned we have language
and code bindings in seven different
languages these provide
types like structs and go typescript
interfaces in node
pages and java in terms of getting
started we have a set of quick start
samples
uh in these languages as well as two
sample applications and a code lab
let's say we're a movie studio recording
a lot of audio
we have hundreds of audio files being
recorded every day
how can we search through these audio
files and find the text
in these files being spoken maybe in
real time
so the idea is whenever i upload an
audio file
to google cloud storage then let's use
cloud
speech to text to extract the text
uh from the audio file and then
add the result to google sheets
let's go to vs code where we can see the
demo
now we're going to show a quick demo and
then dive into the code
on the left hand side let's see uh
google spreadsheet
and on the right hand side you'll see a
google cloud storage bucket
um i'm going to pass some files
and upload them into our google cloud
storage bucket these are some audio
files of me speaking chinese
and english and so you'll see the
left-hand side
we have uploaded these files and it's
been added to our spreadsheet in fact
all the audio
been recognized and transcribed into
text
it's like etc
so that's really cool how did we do that
um well let's go dive into the code so
we use events for cloud run
um but first let's talk about our cloud
run service
so we provided a docker file
just specifying our base image of node
14
and we're going to start we're just
creating an express app
here we have uh just a
slash a health check and then
slash for post requests we extract the
cloud event
from the http headers and then
we get the bucket name and the object
name
from the cloud event subject
and then we use those bucket and object
names
to get the actual speech so what this
is doing is it's calling this file
speech
a s and calling the speech to text
function that's the bucket and the file
name it downloads
the file and then it
reads the file um locally
and audiobytes and base64
and then now we're going to prepare our
request to the
cloud speech text api so we're going to
provide audio bytes
we're going to provide linear 16
encoding since this is a wav file
we're primarily trying to
understand chinese so our language code
is
ch cn but we also
want to recognize english and so we
provide the alternate language codes of
english then we call the api
we join the result um and then
we just want the actual stream and then
let's return that
next we're going with that result
we go and add a new row so how do we do
this
well uh we have a different file
sheets.js
we provide a spreadsheet id here we have
an uh
function so here we use a
service account credentials we have the
local file
we downloaded prez.js
and we provide the spreadsheet scope
we've already
shared the google spreadsheet
with this service account email until it
has access to
that spreadsheet that's private and then
we append some values
so with that spreadsheet id the range
isn't needed we're going to provide a 2d
array of value um which is just an array
of
our results and so we just
append the the values
and then we say 200 okay to the
cloud brown api we're all good um
and that's it now how did i create my
trigger
well you can see um
cloud run it's really great how triggers
are separate from your service so
that you can create and delete triggers
without having to
redeploy your service um so we can see
here um
that if we go
and list all of our triggers
we have a trigger here set up um
and in fact we can go create one like i
was doing before
of simply creating a new trigger
that's separate maybe we want to
make a separate triggered this
and then it's really quick and easy um
in my opinion at least uh it takes two
or three seconds
um and then
it works but sometimes it takes a little
bit longer but
but done and that's how you create a
trigger
[Music]
and you can list all your interviews
that's probably the demo
uh hope you liked it
[Music]
i think my chinese college professor
would be proud
and thanks
well we just saw was a demo of deploying
a cloud run service
um creating an event trigger we
uploaded some audio files a google cloud
storage bucket
which then fired an event creating a
request
to cloud run which uses the google
speech to text api
plus the google sheets api
so in summary we talked about the rise
of microservices
the cloud events specification events
for cloud run
and a demo experience sign up for
private preview today
here are some links to sign up for cloud
run and club run on gke
public preview is in september 2020.
thanks so much my name is grant you can
tweet at me
at grant timmerman on twitter or check
out my code
at github.com don't forget to smile all
right
and i hope you have a fantastic next